so when i first heard about your program
and i've talked a lot as i say a lot of
people who have used your program
there were a couple things that jumped
out of me because i too am kind of a
math-minded guy
the first one was when you talk about
the debt snowball you start with small
to large you list all the debts and you
say okay you've got a 200
debt pay that one off first and you know
build up to the big debt
and i'm sitting there going okay well if
you have a 200 debt at two percent
interest and a ten thousand dollar debt
a ten percent interest
why not start with the one with the high
interest rate it's mathematical
blasphemy
it really is for a nerd like me it's
like fingernails down a chalkboard we're
doing it wrong you know
we're doing it wrong but the thing is if
you go to the y
and you sweat and you drink water and
you don't eat white bread
and you gain weight you will quit
and the same thing getting out of debt
you need some quick encouragement
you need to go this might work and then
you pay for another one you go well this
might work
you pay off another one you're like
getting the neighbor in here this might
work hey baby come over here look at
this we paid
and you start to get this thing
happening it's called hope
and uh you actually believe it's gonna
happen and so and what happens is the
more people get excited
the more they believe the deeper they'll
sacrifice
and the faster they get out and so this
debt snowball thing even though it's
um you know it it's a paradox even
though
that it works it works and people don't
get out of debt
using the other because they get stalled
out and i was just laughing we tell our
audiences
you know if we were doing math we
wouldn't have credit card debt in the
first place it's not a math problem
so i want to ask also about who kind of
your target audience is
because you know i think that there are
certain situations right i'm i
came from a middle class background by
the time i was you know
a teenager a late teenager i'd say we
were sort of upper middle class
and i incurred debt for college i
incurred debt for law school
you're very anti-debt for college i
agree with you that many college debts
are worthless but
for for my wife for example she's a
doctor as people know
and she went to medical school and she
also went to pre-med for
for undergrad you know are there any
situations in which you think that
taking out college debt is worthwhile
well i just don't teach people to borrow
money the shortest path between where
you are and wealth
is to stay in control of your largest
wealth building tool which is your
income
now that puts some serious hurdles in
place when you're going to law school
or you're going to you're going to go to
med school
but i talk to people who go to med
school and they find a way they get
scholarships
they um they do fellowships uh the md
phd program there's all kinds of ways to
do it
but it's tough it's tough but so is
paying off 250 000 freaking dollars in
debt
that's tough too so um you're going to
pick you're tough
you just got to pick which one i mean
and that's sort of i guess the question
because i it sounds like there are
certain situations like
these there are situations in which if
you have to have a government-sponsored
debt it seems to me those are the
situations in which it's a bad idea to
really take out debt if you've got to
take out a student loan
from the government in order to go major
in gender studies good shot you're never
going to be able to pay that off
but there are certain professions where
the the
income coming out is going to be good
enough that there's a reason the bank is
giving you a low interest loan
if you're if you're taking out a loan
for pre-med they're presumably giving
you that loan hoping they're going to
get knowing or having
actuarial tables suggesting they're
going to get paid back on the other end
so you know are you supposed to forego
federally insured loans too
and the the inherent problem and it
becomes a policy problem when you get
right down to the core of it with 1.4
trillion dollars now in student loan
debt
we're basically loaning 18 year olds who
have never had a job
and want to get a degree in left-handed
puppetry up to 145
000 i mean we the people are stupid
we're really stupid that we're
guaranteeing these loans i mean because
there's no guidelines on this whatsoever
and the parents many times don't care
don't bother to be involved or don't
know
how to lead their kid you know they're
like well they're 18 they make their own
decisions
that's probably not a good idea you know
maybe maybe we put your arm around a
little junior and say you know
we really do need to get a degree in
something other than you know
poke german polka history let's try
something else you know let's try to get
something actually as marketable
and that you can put some tools in your
belt to earn a living so you live in my
basement when you're 32. let's have a
plan here
and it's funny that you come at this
from a different angle from people like
peter thiel obviously but you end up in
exactly the same place
which is college is very often a waste
of time maybe you ought to just be going
out and learning a career apprenticing
yourself
actually making something yourself i
don't think it's a waste of time at all
i mean higher education we just
completed one of our ramsey
personalities chris hogan we just
completed the largest
study all millionaires ever done we
stayed 10 165 of them
and um the vast majority of them have a
four-year degree
uh they didn't do that they didn't use
debt to get it though that's what's odd
uh 68 of them have a four-year degree
and almost none of them went to prestige
schools though
most of them went to state schools and
community colleges and that kind of a
thing
and uh but you know it turns out being
smart being educated is a good
thing it's just you know what are you
studying and what are your expectations
but it just breaks my heart when i get a
young lady calling me from atlanta last
week on my show and
you know she's got 165 000 in student
loan debt for a master's degree in
sociology and she makes 38 thousand
dollars working for the state of georgia
i mean where were her parents where
we as a culture failed her to tell her
that was going to work
but then you can't throw the baby out
with the bathwater and say well
education isn't a good idea
but we're just stupid about education
that's the paradox so
you know as far as you know taking on
deb and i i'm focusing on that because
this is one of the areas where
as you say you know like the the kind of
statistically minded folks look at you
and they're
they it sounds like blasphemy so talking
about entrepreneurialism so when you
look at the number of businesses that
are started
in the united states and that are
successful the percentage that were
started
off of some sort of loan from family
from friends from a bank
there there are a lot of businesses that
were started off at least with somebody
investing who was not the original
person where where you know our business
for example
was started off with an investor and we
went to the investor and we had an
obligation to pay off the investor
and our business doesn't exist without
us actually borrowing money and then
using it to build our business and then
paying back the investor
and that's true for an enormous number
of publicly traded companies you know
is there a happy medium here or do you
really believe that it's just a matter
of scrimping and saving until you can
get together enough money to start the
business because sometimes
you actually do need a spend of scale in
order to make sure that you can get
launched
well if if you're an income i mean if
you're in game as an ipo
if you're wanting to go public you're
probably dealing with a vulture
capitalist at that point i mean you're
probably venture capitalist you're
probably
you're about to get yourself into a
situation where somebody owns your soul
and that's going to be part of the
process if you're doing something like
you guys are doing
you've got an angel investor that's
that's setting you up and
believes in your cause and that gets you
going in my case we started on a card
table in our living room
we've got 806 employees today
we'll do about 200 million in revenue
this year we've never borrowed a dime
but it did take us 20 years you know 20
years later we're an overnight success
yeah
it sounds like a pretty good plan i mean
20 years to 200 million dollars in
revenue and a bad thing so it worked out
so when it comes to kind of personal
character how much do you think that
financial decisions are about education
of people to make the right decisions
and how much is it about actually being
able to
put off what you want for what you need
now that's called maturity the ability
to delay pleasure
and um that is a character quality
integrity there's a high correlation
between
integrity wholeness not just telling the
truth and honesty but this
full-on integrity you are who you are
all the time that's integrity
and not only do you tell the truth not
only do you honor your word in
situations
high data point correlation between that
and the ability to build wealth
this idea that you cheat your way to the
top is mythology
it truly does not work out there i mean
think about it if you go to the local
car place and get your car worked on he
cheats you you tell everybody you know
and you don't tell everybody you know
and if you go in there and he says oh
this was 35 cents i fixed it don't worry
about it you tell everybody you know
because you just found a unicorn
you know what i mean so where the guy
just did the right thing and and you
you send your family your friends and
that's how you succeed in business
you do the right thing it's how you
succeed in life you do the right thing
integrity the ability to delay pleasure
the ability to say
you know i'm going to give up something
today i'm going to live like no one else
so that later i can live and give like
no one else that's the way we say it on
the show yeah
one of the things that i think is so
fascinating about your approach is that
it is an approach that is driven by
personal responsibility so much of
what's going on
in the country in politics generally is
driven by precisely the opposite
attitude so
you're smart you stay away from politics
i'm in politics full-time and it seems
like politicians
make bank off of basically telling
people that nothing they do is their own
responsibility and that everything that
is wrong in their life can be blamed on
outside forces
in america how much of people how much
of of what's bad in people's lives do
you think can generally be blamed on
the decisions they make and how much can
be blamed on on outside forces if you
had to balance that out
well i i think you can be born into a
situation
where um you don't
you know you you're i grew up in a
neighborhood where people said stuff
like the little man can't get ahead
it was a victim mentality blue collar
thing it's like you know the the union
will take care of you
the government will take care of you i
sure hope we can elect a you know
president or congressman will take care
of us because the little man just can't
get ahead on his own
and and is is that a reality yeah if you
think it is
if you think you can or you think you
can't you're right henry ford said you
know and so
there's a reality to this and so the
belief is the real privilege
it's not the skin color and it's not the
socio-economic thing it's the belief in
the culture you come out of
i mean i grew up in tennessee and uh
we're hillbilly culture
my my family scotch irish and proud
hillbillies
uh of the best of the best kind and
an interesting bunch they'll fight you
for their freedoms
and yet sometimes they'll adopt that
victim mentality
and a whole bunch of those folks um i
mean
jd did a nice book hillbilly elegy that
indicated that probably that's
a bunch of us are who elected trump uh
but it was all that
he was a little bit reagan-esque in that
it's up to you
i'll just make it where you can win you
know i'll do it for you
and there's a different message there in
that ideology but you know the problem
is
if you start to believe someone else is
going to fix your life whoever it is
your employer
your mommy the president the congress
you're screwed
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional
glorious leftist here don't ask me why
that's called science
to take advantage of this amazing
opportunity just hit the like button